everyone welcome to the
last but very much not least talk for
today it's my honor
to introduce aviv victorson from the
institute of advanced study talking
about the symptotic spectra which is a
joint work on with euro and zwieda
okay hi
uh
yeah it's great to be in person in
berkeley i
i'm sorry for all the people who
couldn't come
[Music]
with perfect weather
the real live conference
uh so uh yeah what i'm going to tell you
about is not new in any
any means
it's a theory that was developed by
uh workers tossing in the late 70s and
the 80s
uh on our
asymptotic spectra
of stanzas and beyond i'll explain
it's the reason um
uh
we
spent a lot of time actually on writing
a modern survey of this uh
theory is that uh since his
work was focused on tensors
and in particular trying to understand
mates with multiplication uh there have
been many other
applications or settings in which theory
applies and i want to
at least mention them
uh
anyway the the survey uh has uh
uh many more and in general has much
more information than the highlights
i'll give you in this uh
uh
50 minute talk uh but anyway those who
are interested in mall there is a almost
a final draft on the
uh
website of uh javon i still didn't put
it online but anyway
we'll be there and we're hopefully we're
going to post it in a in a couple of
weeks so it's a beautiful theory and i
want just to give you you know some
uh
main uh insights from it and uh
tell you in particular why it's about
optimization where symmetry is there but
yeah
a lot more beyond that so
uh this more or less a plan of the talk
i want to start uh
just by just in general motivation
motivating this framework which comes
from just understanding asymptotic costs
and amortization
then
talk specifically about the basis
multiplication problem its complexity
and tensors and tensor rank
uh
i'll then generalize it to the setting
in which uh source presents this theory
which is a setting of pre-ordered
semi-rings i'll explain what this is and
i'll just tell you about one
setting very different than uh
it's just a setting of graphs where
somehow you capture instead of tensor
rank you capture the famous channel
capacity
and theory helps you know studying that
and many other
uh
settings uh
i want to
then the main theorem of this theory is
the duality
com so i want to expect what will
explain the duality theorem and what are
these asymptotic
uh
spectra
that's related to real algebraic
geometry generalizes the linear
programming duality and it's related in
several ways to positive standards in
for polynomial systems
maybe i'll give you a hint why this is
i want to show that the power of the
duality theorem i'll tell you about uh
the
shanghai celsius which is very important
for matrix multiplication how it follows
directly from this duality theorem
um
i want to talk about the structure of
asymptotic spectra in general why it's
important and
why you want to understand it and i want
to get to we'll see if i get there too
so sense
theorem for the spectrum of the of
making multiplication or
connectivity uh
of uh that spectrum maybe talk about we
extended it to tensor networks so maybe
i'll talk about them but
i have no particular plan of reaching
the end you can stop me with any
questions i want you to understand
what's going on what's the
uh what's the game what's the game
who's against who so motivation so
uh it's basically about
just asymptotics in general
and amortization
and you can think about it's really hard
to talk with this thing
when to breathe
uh
you think about the general set you know
some universe
you can think of it as a you know some
maybe task may be computational
it can be you know some combinatorial
objects like graphs
maybe
you know economic things like you know
items you want to sell or buy
so there are motivations from all sorts
of well then some function
let's say to the natural numbers which
tells you the cost
or the complexity well it depends maybe
for computational task it's a complex
circuit complexity of a problem
here maybe some parameter the click
number or the metric size of a graph it
can be the cost of something you buy or
sell
some functions uh that we are trying to
understand so it can be
causal
parameters etc
and
often this is uh
you know difficult so f may be difficult
to understand
and one relaxation you can do when
you're trying to understand this
function is to think about uh amortized
complexity you say what's the course of
having
to compute or to perform many times the
same task
okay so
you can think of it additively or
multiplicatively so maybe
uh if s is uh
is in this
uh universe you want to understand
uh f of s but you may want to understand
maybe
f of n times s
so performing this task n times
uh maybe it's
will be the limit
so in general
so n times us and
maybe you want to understand some
asymptotics like how does it behave
if we want to amortize it so f of s may
be the limit
of n goes to infinity
the cost of ns
divided by n
the limit choose exist because this
would be sub additive
so you can think of it multiplicative
multiplicatively which is uh with this
you know will be more convenient for us
it you can do either just by
exponentiating or taking logarithms of
for us we will actually
prefer to look at
to be the limit
of
f of s to the n
one over n so you can think of s to the
n also as n copies performing end copies
of n is just written multiplicative the
y and then you
by taking the wood
and
this is sometimes easier to understand
and
it's a relaxation so sometimes it is
easier
and they have better properties and
maybe as interesting or in fact
comparing f
the relationship here
uh is really interesting that's what's
being often called the
economy of scale so can you save if you
you know on average if you perform the
same task many times
so you want to understand so the case
that
uh
f
tilde is
is much much smaller than
than f this is called the
the case where we have economy
of scale
and there were
many examples
in the in fact the channel capacity
which are not uh defined but
um
famous
result of
alone
answering negatively a conjectural
channel is that the human capacity you
can achieve economy of scale
and
appropriately defined also
one of the
most famous examples where you can do a
task many times
uh
in computational complexity it's just
computing matrix vector products
for random fixed random matrix matrix
vector products will take n by n will
take n squared operations but if you
have n vectors to do it on then you can
run the matrix multiplication algorithm
and pair of x or you do much better
so
nice respect
so computation on the other hand
uh there are situations where f tilde
will be
actually quite
similar to f
and that's the case where we we say we
have
a direct product of direct sum theorem
there are many examples
here if you if you
define appropriately tensor products of
lps or
sdps then the value actually multiplies
so
p
sdps
uh there are famous examples in
computational complexity coming from
hardness amplifications i mean you may
know or not know some of these and i'm
just listing some
like so lemons
parallel the petition theorem of a
petition theorem of onerous in uh two
player gangs very important pcp theory
information complexity for communication
complexity
and
and others
of course you saw expressions of this
form also in in chorus talk
those who are here
so it's very natural and uh
we are going to study a particular uh
type of
family of universes for which we can say
something general about with
starsen's
theory so let me talk about again you
can stop me anytime with questions right
let me talk about matrix multiplication
so yeah we want to compute the products
of two major cells let's say i
and b there are n
and this is a bilinear function right so
this uh
yes matrix multiplication and
uh
you know
applied to a and b
gives you a b
and squared inputs uh and two underscore
inputs and square outputs
uh
what's the complexity of this well it
turns out that it's not hard to see that
what we care about is the multiplicative
complexity
how many products gates do we need in an
arithmetic circuit to evaluate this
uh
it turns out that uh
it's easy to see that additive
complexity doesn't matter it will always
be at most multiplicative one so this
really asymptotically is what governs
the
the behavior and of course uh you know
everybody knows source and famous
theorem
that
in 69
prove that
this multiplicative complexity maybe
i'll give it a name
okay let me before i state this let me
relate it to
things the rank and the united states
already as a result contender rank
any bilinear function like this is a
tenzo
and
for example this major multiplication
tensor will be
uh a tensor of size n squared by n
squared by n squared so in generally in
general when i talk about tensors let's
say
uh this will be an element of f to the
in terms of several times in this
workshop so it's just i'm looking uh
here just at
you know
three dimensional tentacles but it will
be interesting just for
reference to think about matrices also
and we can
everything i'll say generalizes to
higher dimensions
but i'll focus on three
and uh it turns out that uh um
uh
multiplication can be represented as a
tensile it is actually so the tensor
makes this multiplication n
uh lives in
and squared
it's so for every field i you know
everything i'll say so for every field
so
so the theory will be i will work for
any field
um
how is it defined you've seen it defined
this this particular tensor
and
in
will be basically in position so there
are n squared entries in each dimension
so
if you are looking at the entry
uh at the entry i j
j k
k i
then the standard will be one and
otherwise
it will be zero so it's a boolean tensor
and it's filled with this entry so
a tensor is a you know linear function
or it's a it's a table a
three-dimensional table
and mason's multiplication is this
particular boolean tensor and tells us
that the multiplicative complexity of
such an algorithm is exactly the
standard rank so what is the tensor rank
but the length of the channel in general
it can go like this
the rank of tenzo
is the
minimum number r such that
t can be written as the sum
of
you know
ui
rank one tensor so these are rank one
tensors
in the case of you know mesocert
there'll be just two of them that's like
one laser system it's the same
definition so what we are interested in
this massive multiplication
we can upper bound it by
giving rank upper bound on its sensor
and what stars and did in 69
his famous results
sort of
somewhat shaking the algorithmic world
is that rank
of the matrix multiplication translator
on two elements
is at most
seven
eight would be the obvious thing oh and
cube is the obvious solution for as a
specification but he managed to do it
with seven
and of course immediately and this is an
important fact
uh mason justification is the
problem for which you can apply the
recursion so this immediately implies
that the the tensor range the
multiplicative complexity
of mm n for any n is at most n to the
log
base 2 of 7 why is this because how
would you compute
you multiply matrices of
some large size n
just divide them
so everybody has seen it
two two by two matrices of blocks of
size and over two and you'll apply this
algorithm at the top level and recurve
and that immediately gives this result
but seeing this result actually uh
means that of course
you know he he could have proved if
there was a different upper bound here
if we could for example
uh you know
could prove that
for some number k
is that most r
this wasn't played by the same recursion
we'll just divide it to k by k blocks
this will mean that
the rank of makes this multiplication m
and
would be at most n to the
log base k of r right
so there is an exponent that covers the
uh
uh you know the growth of these numbers
and where does this come from it comes
from an asymptotic version as you see i
mean we could have you know fixed any k
here so what we should really look at is
not the rank
of you know two by two mixes
multiplication but actually on the limit
of
what the terms of power i mean think of
k the power of two what is how it
behaves in the limit as we take you know
higher higher powers so what we are
really interested in
is whatever it's called the
the asymptotic rank which is exactly an
object
written down here
of
any sense of t like the terms of matrix
multiplication of two by two makes sense
or anything so would be the limit
as the m going goes to infinity
of the rank
of the tensor power of
tm times
1 over m
okay so everybody's
happy with this definition so it's like
tensor
power of a tensor is just like uh the
tensor power of a matrix right
and the power of a matrix is still a
matrix so
and the nintendo power three-dimensional
tensor is still three-dimensional power
a tensor much larger
space
so these these things will turn from a
to a to the end b to the m and so on
okay so we are interested in this so
here you see a setting where the
asymptotic complexity is the complexity
you want to look at it's not just the
relaxation if you want to study
algorithms formative multiplication you
really want to understand
the asymptotic rank of the matrix
multiplication tensor in fact
if you prove any
upper bound if so stratham happened to
prove an upper bound on the length but
if you proved it
on the asymptotic rank the same result
would follow
right
and
the famous you know
omega parameter omega is
the infimum
like that
one n you can write it n to the omega
but this is the same
as writing letter rank
mm2
because you know you can go to
tens of powers of course you will only
be dealing with cancers with basic
multiplication those sizes are powers of
two but you know up to concert it
doesn't matter yes so can this
asymptotic rank depend on the field
yes of course
yeah it can change a lot and yeah but
the whole theory does not depend on you
yeah
okay so
any other question so
we we we see that uh you know we are
interested in the tendril rank this is
of course i didn't mention in terms of
rank has zillions of applications you
can start mentioning them statistics
machine learning
quantum gravity gravity in fact general
relativity whatever you want
understanding the rank is is important
for many reasons and
we are focusing here on understanding
rank of uh
uh massive multiplication but
uh in this context we'll see that
looking at tensors in general is uh is
valuable even if we want to understand
just
uh the terms of rank of matrix
multiplication so
good so i uh i introduced uh
this asymptotic
uh rank of matrix multiplication it's
motivated by the fact that it's really
the two complexities govern the torque
approximate of
matrix multiplication and
it motivates
the following uh let me just look at the
rank in slightly different way and this
is where symmetry will be
cleared
the race is better
it's just black it doesn't
to the length from previous stocks
yeah it was blue
yeah so over complex numbers
uh
i think it is but
yeah i'm not
it's
i'm not i'm not i'm not absolutely sure
maybe they are really it turns out very
simple with small tons of rank and you
perturb them randomly and the randomness
causes uh yeah i'm not sure
so we have this asymptotic complexity
and it motivates
uh an asymptotic all the way to shadow
but before what let's see how to
interpret
this definition of rank
one way of saying it is that
i want to
activate this
uh
the length of
t i want to say this is most r
so i wrote it in one expression but i
want to write it in another
if
t
is less than
[Music]
the identity tensor
which is
r by r by r but just a diagonal tensor
the tensor which
has one of them the diagonal
and what do i mean by this reduction and
this is where the symmetry is coming i
mean you can
the tensor rank would not change if i
change do a linear transformation on any
of the sides like if i
do a linear transformation here
some matrix a applied to this base i do
some ssb
to this space and make this c applies to
this space actually even going to uh
you know f to the a prime b to the f to
the b prime after the c prime i just
uh change basis or just reduce
uh in any way
so take arbitrary matrices and i can
transform the identity major so this
means
that there exists matrices abc
when i apply
a b c
to the identity tender side oh i get
t
this is the same for matrices as pre and
post-multiplying by other matrices you
can only only reduce the rank so that's
the order that we get
on tensors here so here i compare
tensors t to
particular tensor but in general you can
say that
d1 is at most d2
if and only if there are such mater says
such that
you know
c1
this is the partial order on the set of
alternators i'm considered ten dollars
of all sizes
and this is a partial role there are 10
volts which in the case at the right
hand side is the identity times those
tell you the terms of rank
okay
and
given the fact that we were interested
in asymptotic ordering so
you know the if we take such limits you
know it means that we have an upper
bound plus little
epsilon uh on the right hand side we
might as well define and that's a key
definition so this is a
this is a
partial order that's given to us so
that's a natural partial order so we
have the parcel order
of pre-order
and now we have the asymptotic
also order which is supposed to capture
the asymptotic rank
and it will be the following it's very
natural so we say that
t1
asymptotically
is less than t2
if
you know if for some large n if
or you know basically for all our then
we have
we limit we take n copies of this
general tensor
we can reduce t prime to it
or t1 t2 we can reduce it and here we
allow
n plus little one
allow a little more so in the limit it
will disappear
okay so this is an asymptotic partial
order and this is a relaxation of
this partial holder
and it's much more
you know i don't know
amenable to analysis it's much more
accessible and we'll see
soon how so
uh first i want to make sure that
everybody is you know it's clear about
but there they don't have the same
dimension right
you don't your dimension can change this
a b and c are not square or not
invertible
like in you know you apply
to a matrix apply pre and post multiply
by an image that says a and b you get
smaller matrix and the rank of this
result is also rank of that so in the
same sense you have just three of them
yeah
okay so we have uh you have this
asymptotic order and this is what we are
trying to understand
so in order to understand this uh we
need to observe
two more and you know so we ours our
universe are already
erases s the universe we are playing
with is the universe of all kinds of
three-dimensional tensors of all sizes
we have a partial order of it but only
but we have also
a ring structure on it that we are going
to use so
so adding and multiplying tensors in
fact multiplying we just saw so
uh so s is the set of standards
we saw a parasol order on them
and
we also have
c1
let me start from products
what is the multiplication
multiplication is t1 times or t2
okay so that's a you know it's a
commutative operation on the space of
turns off
and addition is
t1
2 by which i mean just putting two ten
rows
you know below each other
just like doing with matrices putting
them as block diagonals
on a bigger matrix so that's how you
write them so that's another
operation so tensors are also semi-ring
is you know sorry
summary
this set and there's a partial order in
fact the parcel order is compatible with
these operations if you
uh you know if you uh
add two smaller sensors and uh you know
your to bigger sensors you'll get a
bigger result and so some multiplication
so
we have this uh
additional prophecy and the final
property that i want
and this is a setting in which the
source and theory will uh apply
is
the existence of the natural numbers in
this summary
right this is like the number the
integer out
right so in the summary so s has inside
it
the integers
this is the set of
so there are the ones that you know we
know this is a total order of the
integers we know it and it somehow
you know allows us to scale the or to
bound the ranks of uh you know other all
other temples that's what we are seeking
the rank of the symbol subsequent
of other tensors
so we saw that
the universe of tensors is a is a
summary it has a partial order and the
natural numbers live it
and in fact sausage considered even
though he is really interested in
tensors and makes this multiplication
he's considering all such
semi rings so
let's see how i'm doing okay
this will probably
take another five minutes
so now i want to tell you the
uh duality theorem so i want to say what
we are interested in and
the
rank in any ordered semi ring any order
simulink
okay so we have a general there
yes
what this this kind of property is
sometimes called the strassen summary
pre-order simmering so we have any
also the oldest
semi-ring
with the integers inside it
and we want to i give you an element
uh
s and i want to
compute uh
the minimum
real number r
so that
the rank of s
is most all right this is finding the
just an optimization problem
what are the constraints on this
optimization problem it's a bunch of
inequalities what are the inequalities
that these are just all inequalities
that exist in this infinitely many maybe
counter uncountably many things of the
form ai
all the relations in the sponsor order
anyway it's some
i don't know space
and in this space will soon make it more
concrete but it's it's a space in the
space
and concerned by these inequalities of
course our relationship between
this you know uh given element and
you know the elements bi and ai maybe
it's the sum of central products of the
others or something
right or maybe there are many ways of
writing this like that
in particular you can write it to the
tensor given its central rank you write
it as a sum of length one tensors
so there are all these inequalities and
you want to solve this minimization
problem
and
so since the
main theorem is the duality theorem it
tells you that this optimum
is equals to
the maximization of something else
will be the maximum of some
some function
and this function will be i'll tell you
its properties
but it will be a function
from the summary
to the non-negative wheels okay so it
looks should look familiar it should
look too familiar from other duality
theorems that you you see or the
minimization problem you like the dual
and the dual will be a maximization
problem with set new set of variables
what will be the variables these are the
variables that associate to every
element as some real number
and what
what kind of properties you know what
is the set of fields that we allow
well
how do you get information from this
set of inequalities in general i mean in
our programming or in other
polynomial
you can certainly this uh this uh
summary right you can add inequalities
you can multiply inequalities
and you know you're saying this
to real values if you do it in a
monotone way preserving the order you
can also use it so that's that's what
you want so
you maximize this overall
fee
of this type which
uh
g of a
so what exactly what you think
now the additive
multiplicative
well you want to normally you want the
integers not to disappear by some
mechanism so fee of one is one so it's
normalized which means that fear of n is
n
and monotone she is one of them
the partial order so
a small b means that
p of a
b
so
put some natural conditions in fact
using these natural conditions we can do
alex is not hard to prove you know this
maximum is at most that minimum it's
always slow bounces
and the main thing is the converse so
they strong duality so that's the main
duality theorem so first i want to make
sure that everybody understands the
statement of this
duality theorem there's a in this very
general abstract setting
uh you know you can still characterize
the optimum of this type of optimization
problems by this
dual formulation
this minimum
is lesser input than where you'll have
10 years yes
particularly
yeah
[Music]
so in particular the rank of s for any s
is
the maximum
over all
so let me call it so this set
this kind of set
a function as is called
x of s and this is the asymptotic
spectrum
because the spectrum of s so this
harmony and this will be the max
of the field
these two four agrees
and more generally
being
foreign
a
is not somewhere equal in that it puts
it all there
then b
if and only for every field
and that's total spectrum
all right so you will characterize this
uh
explicitly this asymptotic order if you
look at it you really care about
asymptotically
uh okay so this is the one i want to
make sure this i get state and i want to
uh oh good
so again questions about just a
statement of that is it important that
you use
integers
yes that's a very good question and in
fact i didn't i didn't i'm not going to
say unfortunately about the proof of
this theorem
uh
but uh
one way i mean we given somewhat
different proof of sorts of soviet
things to some duality servant of
the
uh
cabbage zone on
on rings but you can do it really
explicitly and give the the food proof
without appealing to anything
uh and in particular you relax
uh these two
rationales one relaxation is
to rationalize
uh
basically
you
if you think well in fact it's not clear
that this is
not an empty set
right
it's not clear
if you think a little bit you'll find
that it's not an empty cell because for
example
if you flatten your tensor to a matrix
in any way like i say
one one of the three
against the other two and you look at
the rank of this matrix for every tensor
you can define it this would be a ring
homomorphism it will be additive
multiplicative because that's properties
of nature strength so this is non-empty
but that's sounds like a trivial
uh element of the spectrum
um
okay
but so now you you wonder
what what can you do with this
okay so first of all uh
what is the structure of this
asymptotic spectrum
you can
at least understand it in some cases in
particular in cases that will be of
interest
if the ring is generated by a constant
number of elements
for example if you are interested in the
matrix multiplication
exponent
you can restrict yourself to the semi
ring generated by matrix multiplication
just
adding it and turn the product in with
the charge that's also simmering and
that's all the properties there
so
if s is generated by some
finite number of elements
then this asymptotic spectrum is really
uh
setting out to decay right because i
claim that
these are ring homomorphisms so they are
you know basically polynomials
if you want to understand the value of
polynomial if you know it's uh
you know in a ring like this if you know
it it's the generators you can just
compute it in anything else so here x
is really uh will be
the threat of you know we can be
identified with a set of
p of a
one
this suppose
fears ak
all these
all these fees so
it looks like a recursive definition but
i hope you understand what i mean it's
sufficient to
just describe it at the generators and
then you know it's for all other values
because any other element of the
simulink is a polynomial in this
element so this is
a subset of
our plus to the case so at least you can
think about it this may be infinite
dimension
and uh
a priori
you know you can ask what is this you
know you can say that it's very to see
because there's polynomials this is a
closed set but what else can you say
well in general there is nothing you can
say
for any closed cells in in the after
decay i can describe for you
a ring which will have this as the
spectrum
so there is no information there so the
question is what information do you gain
in tensors in the matrix multiplication
similarly what what else do you know and
let's see one thing we can
we can know we can infer from this it's
extremely important powerful for matrix
multiplication algorithm okay that
follows from duality
let's see if my ceo is correct that the
racing blue is easier than erasing red
black yes
amazing
so i'm
here at the tau theorem
so yeah i didn't say it but if you think
about
this in this case the final the
generator's case
you can now think of these inequalities
actually as polynomial inequalities so
you are in the real algebraic
geometry setting you are maximizing you
also minimizing some
polynomial expression
subject to some polynomial constraints
observe polynomial constraints and you
translate it to a dual
which uh there are papers of sweets and
some others in the actual in the last
five years or so
which
actually so you it should remind you of
the positive style of that
case and the
uh the dualistic control with algebraic
geometry there are several such
statements like this and he connects
these uh type of results to sources
duality uh zero and one you know they
are incomparable but the relationship
between them if you remove one of one of
the operations here either one you left
with only additions or only
multiplication then you get a semi
and then you can check that this duality
theorem generalizes just linear
programming that's what happens in let's
say you look just at addition you'll see
that
you you get
something that generates linear
programming and in a finitely generated
case it is
in our program duality so
let's say connection to optimization in
a
little algebraic geometry so
i want to tell you maybe this is the
last thing i'll have time to tell you
is the how to apply to make this
multiplication algorithm
so i want to tell you about shane hargis
tau zero
and i don't know how many people
have heard about this but one way to
understand why ciao tao is because of
omega you remember omega is the exponent
of matrix multiplication tau is another
greek letter somehow greek letters are
really popular today
for bad reasons
so here's the trivial example of
the
tau serum
here's an example
if i prove
suppose i approve that the rank
of the matrix multiplication tensor
or it may be for some n
is it most end to the tau
so i have an algorithm right
if i pull this then
it says that omega is a master
is a triviality right i have an
algorithm maybe there's a better one but
it's at least one algorithm okay
so this is what china is asking
suppose
that i have another algorithm it's not
for matrix multiplication but it's for
the direct sum of two matrix
multiplication you know you have to
multiply n one by n one matrices and
then you have to multiply and two by and
two makes this is not completely
disjoint so the variables maybe you have
an algorithm for this that's fast
so suppose
you discover renko even asymptotic rank
of mm
and one
and two
suppose you discover that let me call it
well how
we see it can be expressed in a form
like this that the n1 to the tao
plus n2 to the top
does this imply that omega is less
so such algorithms useful to bound the
matrix multiplication exponent so you
remember here
stressing used you know source proved
that length of
mm2
is at most seven and this immediately so
seven is two to the power log two of
seven and this implied that
uh omega was less than something like
2.8 much less than three right that's
what star sensitive
then also shane did the same he found a
clever algorithm for something like this
actually it was more complicated i'm not
going into excite there was actually an
upper bound for the rectangular matrix
multiplication but doesn't matter the
same principle he found an inequality
like this and used it
and the theorem this actually happened
to the river so
in sean hackett's results
an application to this kind of method
he used
something like this to prove that omega
so he pulled some length bound like this
and he got omega is at most
2.55 so you see such inequalities are
useful
so
you have to
cross out this so what they proved is
what's called the asymptotic sum
inequality and they said that
if
you can prove any upper bound like this
okay on
and sub k and sub i
is that most
some of it's about
to the tao
this implies omega that's right
so
if you so that's a theorem that's this
the tau theorem
asymptotic sum inequality and if you
think about it what it really means is
that there's no way to save that this
direct sum problem there's no way to
save on it
so it's equivalent
to saying that this
symbolic rank of the direct sum of mn
and i
is
the same actually it's you know it's
even the tighter bound that
stress and
i said
the source and proof is the sum of the
asymptotic banks
okay so it's another scenario we talked
about direct sum in the in the beginning
when you appear you have no economy of
scale and because you have no economy of
scale any bound like this gives you a
bound on omega on the exponents of
massive classification
okay so that's the com let me tell you
about the proof of this theo i mean i
think that
maybe the most i can do
um
the proof is really simple when you have
duality i mean it's it's sort of
amazingly simple
so what is this expression think that
the ni's
are two to the
ai are just powers of two
right
so this means that each one of them is a
tensor power some ki ai tensor power of
mm2 so it's a polynomial in
this
single uh generates or mn2
okay so
if we have if our our ring is generated
by one element that you should think of
this element for this purpose or
as being the massive multiplication
of two by two matrices
you know such a sum is a sum of powers
so it's just a polynomial in
this uh this element
i claim that uh for any
fee in our spectrum in the spectrum of s
and for every polynomial
let's say with integer coefficients it
doesn't really matter
think of it as a variable here so
everybody is happy with this and we feed
the ring homomorphism it adds some
additions and multiplies the
multiplication so this is a trivial uh
thing but now
let's see what is the
and this is
this is a particular polynomial right
it's some particular polynomial
so what do we what do we do we want the
rank
the symptotic rank of
p of a
this sum
by duality
this is a maximum
overall feeling the sympathetic spectrum
of
yes
right
and now you can move the fiend side and
the maximum inside by monotonicity
and this comes to be
p of
[Music]
and you get the right answer
this is it
it's amazingly powerful
okay so that's one application there are
other applications
i will not talk about them but since i
have just a couple of minutes let me
tell you what i didn't tell you about
it turns out that
it's really nice that you can infer
something from inequalities like this
but what do you do if you know you have
you know
the rank of some direct sum
of major multiplication terms or is it
most the sum of some other
multiplication terms so here we have an
integer
suppose you have here another direct sum
then this inequality is it's just
relating to polynomials not relating
polynomial to a real number so you
cannot use monotonicity
what do you do well it turns out that
i i would have pictures but let me not
get into this let me just say
that if you want to derive algorithms
from
inequalities of rank of one direct sum
and the rank of another direct sum
then you cannot hope for anything if you
don't know more about the spectrum
what do we know about the the asymptotic
spectrum of nicest multiplication we
don't know much
but we know this much
the synthetic spectrum of matrix
multiplication which might as well be
the
this
you know that subset of the wheels it's
one dimensional
and so here are the wheels
and we know that four
two to the two is the is in there
and we know also that two to the omega
is there because at the maximum it can
be
and we don't know anything in the earth
so it turns out that
this upper bound means that you know
basically if we have a polynomial so the
spectrum believes here it's a cross set
maybe it's a union of intervals
here we have r minus p of
o minus p of x given by this
is non-negative on this spectrum and if
it cuts here at that point ah we get an
upper bound on it
that makes us multiplication exponent
but if we have an inequality of the type
i was talking about you know between two
uh
you know maybe we must have a
something that looks like this
you know something that may look like
this
which is also positive on the spectrum
but it you know how do we know how do we
bound this maximum
well there would be one easy way if
this spectrum was connected so we knew
another more information about the
spectrum if we knew it was connected it
was one interval
then
uh we would this cannot happen i mean it
would have to look something like i know
maybe like maybe it would look like this
but since we know point here we would
know
an upper bound so anyway
the absolute is that uh the last theorem
i want to state
that the
matrix must be the spectrum of the
matrix multiplication
is
connected
so you can in a firmware he proves
something else he proves it for you know
rectangular massive multiplication we
generalize it to all
change those networks this kind of
connectivity and first in fact star
convexity of the spectrum in higher
dimensions
uh but i guess i have no time to tell
you
anything about uh yeah you know the
proof unless you ask me some questions
and uh
yeah i guess i almost covered almost
what i wanted to
talk about so let me end answer
questions very much
so if i properly understand like the
computational model that potentially one
can look for
faster multiplication algorithm doing
some checking some real inequality some
optimization like real like real numbers
optimization
yeah
yeah and the current one they're
completely discreet
it's like really no no when people now
looking for the like faster all these
like discrete so you can you compare
that some dimensions within other
dimensions yes they do more things they
do they are either even you know even
story they don't just use although this
is used for routinely the other things
about computing partial message
multiplication with laser methods you
but yeah they basically prove
inequalities of this type and in fell
from them
you know bounce of the exponent
yeah any other question
any other questions
so this
is proof that you that you are showing
right so
you're saying you take an algorithm
for uh some multiplication then this
gives a bound for uh oh my god on uh on
omega which then
is somewhat explicit yeah
so you can uh yes it's explicit in the
sense that you can translate into you
know all this is using the asymptotics
so what you know this
there are symptomatic inequalities right
so what you will do is you say there is
some finite size which
approximate the boundary got here
by maybe an epsilon and you guess a
bound that like oh my god
plus epsilon for any absolute only one
yeah and this would be an explicit
algorithm probably expensive because the
numbers would be low but yeah
theoretically they're talking about that
exactly yeah so you get like a super
constant in front
which you don't care about so it's cf
sign it's not the the constant is one
problem and the other thing is that the
the type 7 is the exponent yes yes
so it's basically for understanding you
know is there is a complexity of massive
multiplication for the elastic
between two to the you know and to the
two plus epsilon
type of foreign of course it would not
mean that we can have a
real software that does in this
time
any other questions
thanks for the talk uh
do you have any sense of whether the
things in the asymptotic spectrum look
like
you know like i guess you have
as as uh
mathias was talking about you have like
the ranks of the
kind of flattenings those are
somehow at least
uh you could write them down as like
you know as in using determinants of
of uh
matrices with entries depending on the
sensor there will be points in the
spectrum there it will come from
flattening of the template
and then they have what you described is
that
these are not this is just the final set
in fact switch yeah what it describes is
that you can actually get an infinite
number of points in the spectrum of
geometric multiplication
of rectangular measures multiplication
that's a three-dimensional space using
this uh you know uh linear combinations
of enthalpy yes so so
there are many other continuously many
other points in the spectrum which they
are
uh you know describing this way we don't
know whether they are everything
we don't know whether research is convex
but trust improved is that it's star
progress
and so when you
of course in the one dimensional case if
you just look at square uh basis
multiplication connectivity
um could you prove that they were at
least like
uh
that the function has like some
expression like is it are they gonna be
polynomials maybe like polynomials and
logs and stuff like that or
no no i mean you could you should think
about the fact that
there's no obvious way
to generate any other point except four
and two to the omega for just square
matrix multiplication so some something
that would be you know illegal
homomorphism that's monotone on the on
this
you know
something is generated by han element
it's not libya that's not yeah it's way
hard to know anything and this book
is extremely direct you have to go with
the rectangular ones and then you have
to do some magic which
we have an interpretation of the paper
as actually is an error collection of 40
nexus multiplication algorithms i mean
he doesn't describe it like this but
i mean the essence of this is a
compression result we chose in every
erroneous in a particular way low
dimensional variables
uh in any given basis multiplication
algorithm set foreign heights
a
perfect angle of two by over two major
multiplication algorithm
and that's you know we are very clever
we're using the asymptotics this gives
the
uh this connectivity result
yeah so lots of details you can find out
in the survey that i think is
happy to get comments uh for anyone
for this case is it decidable
i think this was studied i'm trying to
remember
okay so another example i mentioned is
the channel capacity yeah it turns out
to be a
maximization problem so it's sort of
suffering but it doesn't matter very
undecidable so a parameter like this in
the context of graphs is undecidable i'm
not sure about that yes
so
one question is that so you're saying oh
if we're trying to find a point between
four and two to the omega but if they're
equal is there any other kind of no if
they are equal then uh this is one point
yeah exactly then you won't be in find
it think about the case d equals two of
matrices right for matrices
there's only one point it's the length
the length is the only ring of
homomorphism of matrices to the
non-negative wheels that is much
frequency relative so this the spectrum
is a single point here the spectrum is
continuous unless it's one point
unless it's right and then is there any
other like
kind of
could be like conjectures that you could
expect as well that don't invoke the
synthetic spectrum then maybe there's
other implications that say oh if the
spectrum is one point then such and such
would happen if it's one point then we
understand everything perfectly so it's
uh you know it's it's sort of
a trivial case in the sense of this
assets exceed it but we don't uh you
know in general more interesting
examples we think it's probably not that
i think of that yeah oh yeah sorry then
the other question be like if it's not a
single point is there any other kind of
you know easier contract statement that
would be implied that at least you can
try to
verify or not verify like is there
yeah so as i said if if you know that
it's
not only not a single point but it's uh
you know connected
then you can show that certain
inequalities will imply bound if you
know that the status convex you would
have even stronger implications you can
have even more general inequalities
inclined about
omega and so on so
uh in some settings in the setting of
graphs which relate to the shutter
capacity then you know that it actually
contracts with the
result of piece of one
so in some cases it's not that it's
convex uh in the case of alexandria
makes its multiplication it's not normal
start from the signal
when you get circuit motor bounds or
something
if it's convenient
because you can like yeah i mean yeah i
should have said that the only reason
i'm in this game is because of
arithmetic complexity that's for me is
the motivation and change of actual
amount of arithmetic complexity robots
this is a part it's a robot for a
particular circuit by a linear circuit
four by linear function counting the
number of uh
of uh multiplication we don't know a
single like we don't know anything
complexity that's the summary of our
knowledge more specifically we don't
know any
explicit example of a function that a
bilinear function requires requiring
more than
you know the size of the input
multiplication after constant we just
don't know that there's major
multiplication just one explicit example
we don't know any
trend law for which the tender one is
bigger than the other side
any other questions
from my online
okay
well thank you very much again
[Applause]